un véritable mouvement de résistance les
franco-ontariens veulent faire reculer
le gouvernement conservateur sur
l'annulation du projet d'université
francophone ils demandent également le
retour de commissaire indépendant aux
services en français on apprendre pour
ça il n'est pas question qu'on va
laisser faire des choses comme ça ou
est-ce que vous vous attaquez nos
institutions devant les bureaux du
premier ministre dans ses partisans
d'oxford sont mécontents j'ai voté pour
lui pour le changement mais aujourd'hui
en tant que francophone je regrette
beaucoup dans l'east ontarien la députée
amanda 6 meur qui a quitté les rangs
conservateurs en raison de ces
compressions a été accueillie comme une
vedette c'est la communauté vraiment
qu'ils sont les vedettes parce qu on est
le visage la francophonie ontarienne
maintenant indépendante elle dit avoir
les coudées franches je pense que les
gens comprennent que même à l'intérieur
le combat va au delà des allégeances
politiques on comprend très bien que
l'ontario peut avoir des certains
problèmes budgétaires et je pense que ce
qui est engendrée par les coups d'un
commissaire à la francophonie
les coûts d'une université sont quand
même pas des coûts qui sont prohibitifs
pour la ministre fédérale de la
francophonie le gouvernement fait fausse
route
hier matin deux de droits linguistiques
la règle est claire lorsqu'on modifie
des lois on modifie les lois pour
renforcer les droits linguistiques
jamais pour les affaiblir
l'envergure de cette mobilisation n'est
pas sans rappeler un autre moment phare
de l'histoire les franco ontariens de
paiement de ressemblance entre dossier
montre avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
on a franchement avec le jugement mon
corps me repère mieux que ça de nombreux
franco ontarien avait milité contre la
fermeture de l'hôpital montfort à la fin
des années 90 sous le gouvernement
conservateur de mike harris
photo grand ce bourg ne veut plus de
bain c'est dans la langue de shakespeare
que l'avocat qui était au coeur de cette
cause s'est adressé au premier ministre
cette bataille dépasse maintenant les
générations soit l'adversité amtrak fois
utopique en ontario passé et si chine et
le gouvernement conservateur de droite
fait valoir qu'il a dit
et en place certains services dédiés aux
francophones notamment en rétablissant
le poste de commissaire aux services en
français sous la direction de
l'ombudsman les pour les franco
ontariens
c'était suffisant qui sait quel côté
sont à radio canada ottawa